how do you ever find the truth if the  only time you consume the news is maybe  you sit down at night and you turn on  NBC or ABC for 15 minutes you know yeah  maybe they're a little biased but I'm  catching headlines how do you explain to  that person that every single thing you  were told on the television set is a lie  how do you explain to that person that  the Biden family is actually a criminal  Network by all all appearances make it  look like a criminal Network when you  look at Tony bobolinski and others and  they'll never find out even on Twitter  because like you just pointed out  anything damaging about this family gets  axed right away I I I feel bad for so  many normal Americans who are obsessed  politicos like us because you have you  live in a world of Make-Believe and you  don't even know it you have no idea is  uh and and seven eight years of it